hi my name is curly and i was born and
raised in los angeles and i love l.a so
for this bring me episode i decided to
invite my friend from tejas texas to
come out here and live a day in my shoes
hi my name is eric and i'm from dallas
texas i'm currently pursuing my massage
therapy license and i'm also involved in
the queer mexican cowboy community here
in dallas i cannot wait to share a
little bit of my world with him i'm so
excited y'all know i love fashion i love
salvadorian food and i love my queer
community so i was so excited to invite
my friend eric out here to experience it
all and possibly get a little bit of his
energy aligned
[Music]
i just landed in la i'm so excited to be
here um i can't believe that i'm here
really
i hear curly has some pretty interesting
things for me uh to do so i'm really
excited to get to it let's do it
first stop because i truly believe that
grooming is so important will be project
q project q does a lot of incredible
work for the lgbtqia plus community in
la so i want you to go get yourself a
nice fresh cut and get ready for the
city
hi i'm eric hey i'm madden i know why
you're here
curly since you're right yes oh yes okay
well my name is madden my pronouns are
they in them this is pepper she them so
here at project q we do haircuts for
homeless and housing and secure youth
that's amazing and when they come in
they get to learn how to be members of
society in a way that their family might
not have had the chance to teach them
yeah and so that is what is at the crux
of project q and it all just starts with
a haircut which you're getting today
are you excited i'm very excited awesome
all right let's do it
so
i really want to get the
uh sides taken care of okay so so then
what i'm gonna say is it would be best
to give you
kind of a low fade here
i love your space by the way thank you
amazing so you've been here for three
years how long has project cube been
around we've been around for nine years
so that is a really big deal yeah you're
and you're still going strong it's
amazing yeah you know we only really
hire queer folks of color we only bring
in people that have had similar
experiences because that shouldn't be
something that you have to fight in the
workplace definitely so you're from
dallas are you visiting us from there i
am visiting from there yeah yeah
i have a great aunt that lives in texas
and
she actually just came out to me she's
like in her 80s that's amazing and she
just came out of the closet so i just
got my hair cut from madden at project
they were amazing
all right let's take a look all right
right i love it
and i feel great i feel how i look which
is incredible honestly i mean i feel
amazing really
thank you so much i found it very
inspiring the work that project q does
for the lgbt community here in la
wonderful well thank you for coming and
experiencing what we do thank you it's
uh inspired me to find a place that'll
do the same back home in dallas
[Applause]
next stop is the pink crow one of my
favorite places in all of la it's where
i go to get my facials don't look at
this and i go to get some spiritual
alignment i know that you want to be a
massage therapist so this is going to be
really good and an informative
experience for you please say hi to my
beautiful friend lydia she's amazing
hi hi eric i'm lydia nice to meet you
so you're here for the reiki facial yes
yes uh curly sent me oh nice i love carl
um have you ever had any type of energy
work done any reiki never this will be
my first time okay energy work is a lot
like um getting a facial but for your
spirit so it's about removing kind of
like the dead stagnant
energy i'm excited um
good good
i'm gonna get started with your
facial massage okay
lydia knows what she's talking about she
knows what she's doing i actually do a
mixture of reiki chronic healing and
some other things like with sound
healing
it was incredible uh i definitely want
to come back i also do something called
cord cutting tying an imaginary string
around certain experiences in your life
and cutting that chord it just means
we're cutting the feeling the energy
behind an experience the energy behind a
memory
it was really exhilarating and and i
definitely released some blockages that
i was holding
you know really so much emotionally
curly thank you so much for recommending
her to me it was such a great great
experience
ah
and finally you will visit the cool and
casual studios where you will meet my
beautiful friend alden there's really
nothing quite like a one-on-one styling
experience so i'm excited for you to
experience this while you're here you
have to eat at one of my favorite
restaurants in all of la is la pabusa
urban eatery
it's run by my two friends juan and
stephanie who were also born and raised
here in los angeles
their proposals were freaking amazing
now i'm heading to cool and casual to
meet alden who's been styling curly for
years and we'll see what he's
picked out for me we'll see if he'll get
me out of my comfort zone when it comes
to fashion
hi eric nice to meet you
i heard that you want to like explore
some new things and so
that's what we're going to do today try
on a few outfits
and keep it in the spirit of what you're
doing but elevate it i'm going to push
your boundary a little bit i'm hoping
for that yeah i'm open to that yeah
since we're first meeting okay i want to
see what you pick out and what speaks to
you and then we'll collaborate and build
on that okay
[Music]
wow i'm loving this sweater
i knew the pants would be a little bit
too big but we have a tailor right
around the corner if you're really into
them trying some high-waisted jeans next
um maybe with this look to get
more casual look wow
so you really wanted to see this shirt
on it fits you perfectly yes
i love it with the jeans i think that
we're just going to cuff the jeans i
feel like that's going to like create a
more modern look
i think that we're going to try it with
the workwear jacket that you had on
earlier um just because monotone it's
like a staple like cool and casual
studios
and it's one of those things that
makes dressing easier because you're not
like what do i wear you know it's just
like i'm wearing blue with blue and then
you have your papa green so we're gonna
try that on and see how we feel let's
show the camera what you're working with
i love this it's really great yeah me
too i really learned a lot uh it's
definitely gotten me out of my comfort
zone when it comes to clothing and
fashion yeah uh you got me to try
high-waisted jeans which i've been
wanting to do yes you look great in them
thank you thank you so i'm definitely
gonna go home and apply it i don't like
it high five yay thanks for coming in
thank you thank you
i feel great this was an amazing
experience a unique experience uh and i
i loved it oh my god eric you look so
good you learned so much from my queer
and fashionable community here in los
angeles and you even had some papoosas
to go with it wow that was a crazy
couple of days i had so much fun while
it's not my first time in la
this experience has made me see la in a
different light and i
i can't wait to come back i am so
thankful that you came out here and
experienced a little bit of my world
you